voilà ma tenue de combat de candidate
pour le best job in the world
cette nantaise participent à la deuxième
campagne lancée par l'office de tourisme
d'australie pour promouvoir si visa
vacances travail d'une durée de six mois
ce qu'elle convoite le poste
d'aventurière alors opération
communication pour défendre sa
candidature
et ça marche six cent mille inscrits au
départ 45 mille vidéos postées dans sa
catégorie
elle monte à cheval saute en parachute
campi j'en passe elle a travaillé comme
apiculteur chercheuse d'or bergère elle
a visité plus de 20 pays et aime surtout
rencontrer les locaux
aujourd'hui la baroudeuse fait partie
des 25 présélectionnés grâce au soutien
de son entourage et à son originalité
pour le premier match aller distribuer
des brins de muguet aux touristes sur la
place du trocadéro et donc avec une
grande banderole avec plusieurs amis on
est parti un petit peu essayé de le
ramener tous les touristes qui puisse me
faire des vidéos dans toutes les langues
du monde des vidéos qu'elle portera sur
les réseaux sociaux et aux devient même
de quitter son poste dans la culture
pour se consacrer pleinement à sa
mission la conférence a rudoyé de ce que
j'ai vu il ya vraiment des très bons
candidats avocats vont sans doute en 25
sur 45 milles forcément il ya des très
bonnes des très bons candidats mais mais
bon j'y crois lui il est très fort
rennes 22 heures il a déjà fait plein de
choses et il a déjà eu un site à lui
depuis longtemps où il poste ses
articles sur ses aventures justement
donc ouais mais je pense qu'il est très
bien
si l'as mantaise décroche le job elle
gagnera 100 mille dollars australiens
soit environ 13000 euros mensuels mais
elle assure que le pays des kangourous
c'est juste pour l' aventure verdict le
15 mai pour les finalistes et le 21 juin
pour les gagnants